[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
consacré à la contre-offensive
ukrainienne au sud et à l'est de
l'Ukraine les manœuvres Ukrainiennes
bousculent les forces russes sur
plusieurs fronts ils avancent dans le
sud avec une ligne de front le long de
la rive du Dieppe au nord-est la
quasi-totalité maintenant de la région
de carquif apparaît désormais sous
contrôle ukrainien elle ouvre donc la
voie vers l'ougoransk depuis samedi les
Ukrainiens ont repris l'imam repris ce
qui a entraîné de lourdes pertes côté
russe Vladimir Poutine a de son côté
signé la loi actant l'annexion des
quatre régions de Donets clouance Carson
et zapporja des territoires qui
resteraient russes pour toujours selon
son porte-parole la Russie a également
annoncé qu'elle s'approprier la centrale
nucléaire de zaporigia le chef de la UEA
d'ailleurs s'est dit en route vers Kiev
les européens se sont mis d'accord sur
un huitième paquet de sanctions alors
cette contre-offensive ukrainienne
est-elle un tournant dans la guerre où
en est la mobilisation des plus est-ce
une course contre la montre avant
l'hiver Poutine pourrait-il perdre la
guerre pourrait-il dégainer l'arme
nucléaire et bien on va en discuter avec
mes invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à
mes côtés à la lazareva bonsoir vous
êtes rédactrice en chef adjoint de
l'hebdomadaire de youkranian oui le seul
média ukrainien il faut le rappeler
éditer en français bienvenue dans le
débat en face de vous le général de
micrincam bonsoir vous êtes ancien chef
de la mission militaire française auprès
des Nations Unies bienvenue à vous
aulecope bonsoir historien spécialiste
de l'Europe de l'Est à l'américaine
University of Paris bienvenue à vous
également Elena Volochine journaliste à
France 24 notre ancienne correspondante
en Russie spécialiste donc bien sûr de
la Russie bonsoir Elena et nous avons
avec nous en début d'émission notre
envoyé spécial à nicolaïve dans le sud
donc de l'Ukraine Gwendoline de Bono
merci d'être avec nous Gwendoline alors
avant de démarrer cette discussion je
vous propose de faire un point en images
avec Stéphanie Pérez de France
Télévisions
un soldat ukrainien plante le drapeau
jaune et bleu sur ce bâtiment de la
région de Carson
à une centaine de kilomètres d'autres
font leur entrée dans un village qu'ils
viennent juste de libérer
des habitants les films et les sales
on entend les combats au loin
la contre-offensive ukrainienne dans le
sud et l'est du pays s'accélère grâce au
soutien militaire américain les lignes
bougent de plus en plus vite dans un
discours conquérant hier soir le
président Zelenski revendique ses succès
ukrainienne réalise des avancées assez
rapides et puissantes dans le sud et
l'est de notre pays des dizaines de
localités ont été reprises cette semaine
aux Russes
sur le front sud l'avancée ukrainienne
est visible sur cette carte en bleu
foncé les territoires reconquis une
poussée d'au moins 40 km en rouge les
positions russes qui reculent chaque
jour un peu plus
ces images de chars ukrainien drapeau au
vent entrant dans les villages repris
galvanisent les troupes et l'opinion
publique les soldats sont accueillis par
des populations marquées par 6 mois de
combat comme ici dans le Dombas
on a vécu dans la cave à cause des
bombardements quand on sortait on voyait
que tout était détruit autour
dans ces zones libérées des dizaines de
véhicules russes abandonnés l'armée de
Vladimir Poutine est en difficulté le
commandement russe ne le conteste pas et
tente de reprendre l'ascendant en
communiquant notamment ses images des
réservistes qui s'entraînent avant de
partir sur le front au plus vite
Gwendoline de mono je démarre avec vous
un autre envoyé spécial leur Ukraine
vous êtes donc je le disais à mikolaïve
dans le sud est-ce qu'on peut dire que
les forces ukrainiennes avancent au-delà
du Nièvre aujourd'hui et que ce front
sud est devenu quelque chose de très
important
alors pour l'instant sur le front sud
les forces ukrainiennes avancent le long
du nez après c'est là où elles ont fait
une personne de plus de 20 km à nous
avons pu confirmer au moins 5 localités
importantes reprises par les forces
ukrainiennes donc c'est une une avancée
qui est significative avec des trous
Prusses qui battent tortrait sur cette
portion du front mais les Ukrainiens
attaquent sur plusieurs directions
différentes ça s'appelle une manœuvre en
pin s'ils le font par petits groupes
appuyer notamment par des tanks c'est ce
que nous a dit un commandant aujourd'hui
c'est évidemment un front extrêmement
important affront difficile aussi
d'ailleurs on était avec des soldats
hier et aujourd'hui et on sent
effectivement que cette percée que ces
avancées sur le front sud et bien ils
font du bien au moral des troupes parce
que c'est un front difficile parce que
c'est un front qui était figé qui était
dans une guerre de position donc vous
avez et bien des soldats qui tiennent
des tranchées qui tiennent des positions
et il y a encore une artillerie russe
qui pilote ses positions tous les jours
tous les jours tous les jours et bien
les soldats font face à l'artillerie
russe et ils ont encore beaucoup de
munitions c'est ce que nous disent tous
ces soldats donc effectivement ça fait
du bien au moral des troupes et puis les
commandants et bien nous disent que
c'est un piège qui se referme quelque
part sur les trous russe puisque
effectivement ce front et traversé par
le fleuve le Nièvre et que les
Ukrainiens s'attaquent systématiquement
aux voies de passage entre les deux
rives que ce soit les ponts ou même les
passages par bateau les ponts mobiles et
donc et bien c'est un piège qui est
effectivement en train de se refermer
sur les trous russe et on se tend encore
une fois quand on parle au commandant
une sorte d'urgence effectivement une
course contre la montre pour prendre le
maximum de territoires avant les pluies
d'automne qui vont qui vont qui vont
arriver et qui qui empêchent en tout cas
qui complique sérieusement les manœuvres
mais également une course de vitesse
avant l'arrivée des hommes qui ont été
enrôlés par le Kremlin pour que le mater
ses lignes de front merci Gwendoline
générale trin est-ce que on est en train
à ce que les Ukrainiens sont en train
d'inverser le rapport de force alors le
rapport de force est inversé déjà depuis
plusieurs semaines il faut se souvenir
depuis 6 mois l'Ukraine était sur la
défensive elle est chercher à ralentir
la Russie alors que depuis plusieurs
semaines elle est à l'offensive avec
deux offensives celles qu'on vient de
voir dans la région de Kerson qui a été
préparé le longue date annoncée ce qui a
provoqué un mouvement des troupes russes
pour aller vers la région de Kerson et
dégager le Nord et à ce moment-là
l'attaque a été lancée par les troupes
ukrainiennes au nord dans la région de
kerkiff qui s'est terminée il y a deux
trois jours par la prise de l'imam et
qui amène à la poursuite de cette
offensive de front exactement dans le
front suite on va regarder la carte hein
on a beaucoup parlé depuis quelques
jours c'est ce que disait Gwendoline
c'est qu'en fait il y a à peu près il y
avait 20 000 soldats qui sur la rive
droite du Nièvre et en fait la manœuvre
Russe pardon ukrainienne consiste à les
enfermer et c'est pour ça que
l'offensive depuis hier on le sait suit
le long d'une Nièvre en fait elle avance
de façon à fixer c'est une vieille
tactique militaire du plus bas niveau
fixé déborder donc on fixe les gens à
l'ouest et on les déborde par le nord en
descendant le long du Nieppe le but
ayant été préparé avant c'est à dire la
rupture des lignes de approvisionnement
de ces troupes à l'intérieur et ces
troupes ont d'ailleurs demandé au
président ont demandé à pouvoir quitter
Kerson a repartir et c'est le président
voilà se replier c'est le président
Poutine lui-même qui a dit non vous
combattez là c'est un peu leur
Stalingrad si vous voulez d'une certaine
façon
stalingradera on pourrait on pourrait
dire ça enfin il y a vraiment un
inversion une inversion effectivement du
rapport de force aujourd'hui en faveur
des Ukrainiens
c'est difficile à faire les affirmations
définitives parce que les combats
continuent les combats sont féroces et
c'est vrai que le Créateur est reprend
tous le jour les villages les petites
villes ça c'est vrai qu'on est sur une
contre-offensif assez réussite mais
après les prévisions disent que cette
guerre va encore durer au moins quelques
mois
est-ce qu'on va parler d'un nouveau
tournant est-ce que cette ville est clé
bon ce sera ce sera symbolique bien sûr
qu'elle sonne à un rôle stratégique
c'est un port extrêmement important sur
le niaque c'est cet apport énorme c'est
pas le Havre mais
ni le Havre ni rotterdom mais c'est un
port fluvial avec accès vers la mer vers
la mer Noire ou vers les régions du Nord
et de l'Ukraine et les régions du sud de
la Russie donc c'est effectivement c'est
un c'est un point stratégique clé c'est
un hub et évidemment ce sera très
symbolique s'il reprenne personne
effectivement est-ce qu'on peut parler
d'une débâcle russe est-ce qu'ils vont
décrocher on a vu Blagnac Poutine il
reconnaît pas totalement une défaitement
fat tout de même un certain recul la
façon de communiquer des Russes a un peu
changé ah mais c'est clairement une
débâcle d'autant plus que Vladimir
Poutine comme sa grippant à enfin il
pensait que parce qu'il le dirait ça
allait se produire il a dit les
populations de ce territoire seront
russes à jamais désormais ce sont des
territoires russes et cela ne changera
plus jamais et bim le lendemain ils
reprennent l'imam donc en fait dans les
frontières qui ont été déclarés comme
étant celle de la Fédération de Russie
parce que les frontières apparemment on
s'est demandé mais quels sont les
frontières de ce territoire c'était pas
très clair et en fait finalement on a
compris que c'était les frontières au
jour de la signature de l'accord de de
la dette du décret d'annexion on va y
revenir voilà donc en fait c'est une
c'est une débâcle absolue parce que
Vladimir Poutine n'a absolument pas
l'habitude d'être
contredit dans les faits par quelque
chose qui sont aussi importantes que et
symboliques que que le rattachement de
nouveaux territoires à la Russie enfin
je veux dire c'est la réalisation de son
rêve impérialiste le plus absolu et il
est contredit directement immédiatement
par l'armée ukrainienne donc c'est une
humiliation vraiment énorme pour
Vladimir Poutine on va écouter le
conseiller de ski il était au micro de
marque Pearlman
nous avons plusieurs activités de
contrefensives sur différentes
directions sur donuts sur le gain sur
carcov
une petite un petit territoire il reste
quelques pourcentages de la région de
kakov qu'on va libérer et après donc on
sort vers sur la région de Lugansk en ce
qui concerne les régions de Kerson nous
avons quatre particularités de notre
contratensive nous frappons tout d'abord
les infrastructures de
d'état-major russe et nous nous cassons
aussi les arrières russes c'est pour ça
que leur résistance est affaibl c'est
comme ça que le résistance est affaibli
en même temps nos frappons sur
différentes directions ce qui disciple
l'attention des Russes disciplent trop
Prusse parce qu'ils n'ont pas assez de
réserve ils savent pas comment les
déployer
[Musique]
nous avons vu déjà que il y a le
contingent déjà très mal préparé très
incontinent mal préparé
parce que les
professionnels dans lesquels on a ils
ont investi beaucoup il y en a presque
plus maintenant sur le terrain et donc
4e chose grâce à la destruction de la
phrase structure de l'armée russe de
leur logistique il sont beaucoup moins
efficaces en ce qui concerne le
contre-feu leur contre-feu
on parle bien de la destruction des
infrastructures c'est un petit peu ça la
stratégie à propos de la logistique
effectivement qui est cassée et et le
fait d'attaquer sur quatre axes à la
région de Kerson qui est justement la
manœuvre de fixation des troupes pour
les retenir là et pouvoir les contourner
et les attaquer ailleurs on parle du
Nord aussi on va regarder aussi une
carte parce qu'elles se font su des pays
avait ce front il y a toujours ce front
nord-est puisque cette ville de Lima
dont on parle beaucoup est tombée aux
mains a été reprise par les Ukrainiens
samedi dernier et ça entraîné
manifestement d'après ce qu'on entend de
lourdes pertes côté russe c'est le cas
là la manœuvre est la même ça a été un
encerclement de Liman avec les troupes
russe qui voulaient partir qui ont fini
par partir d'ailleurs une partie mais il
y a eu tout de même ils ont abandonné
énormément d'armements de munitions
voire même des blessés et des morts
qu'ils ont laissé sur place et cette
offensive vous savez c'est le problème
de la dynamique de la victoire pour les
Ukrainiens il y a une dynamique de la
victoire est-ce que ça entraîne une
dynamique de la russe on va le mesurer
dans quelques jours mais
pas parler
enfin on ne mesure tous les jours si
vous voulez donc tous les jours on
pourra dire oui ça progresse et ça peut
très bien s'arrêter 48 heures après mais
pour l'instant il y a cette dynamique de
la victoire parce que ce sont des forces
qui ont été bien préparées la manœuvre a
été bien montée et ce sont pas les
forces qui combattaient au départ ce
sont des forces qui ont été préparées
derrière pour être des troupes d'assaut
si j'ose dire et elles étaient équipées
en particulier avec des ponts pour
pouvoir franchir les rivières de façon à
ne pas perdre de temps parce que ce qui
se passe souvent c'est que les troupes
prennent puissant arrêter par les
rivières par les champs de mines etc là
ils ont fait du franchissement très
rapidement et qui continue l'objectif en
fait c'est d'aller plus vite que la
capacité des Russes à réagir et
commencer que le système russe est très
rigide qu'il monte quasiment au Kremlin
pour prendre des décisions il n'y a plus
de professionnels sur le terrain comme
disait le conseiller de zelins qu'il n'y
a plus de professionnels russes sur le
oui mais même même l'armée russe va
demander au Kremlin ses ordres alors que
l'armée ukrainienne c'est la
subsidiarité les chefs sur le terrain
sont capables de prendre des décisions
d'initiative et donc d'aller très vite
ça c'est je crois que c'est un point
essentiel ça c'est toute la structure du
commandement qui est complètement
différente chez les ukrainiens et qui
est beaucoup plus efficace parce que un
sergent un sergent ukrainien peut
prendre une initiative s'il voit
l'opportunité il a le droit de le faire
il a été entraîné comme ça c'est une
méthode américaine d'ailleurs alors
qu'un colonel russe il doit téléphoner
au général qui doit téléphoner au
Kremlin pour demander la permission de
de faire de de prendre telle ou telle
décision c'est la grande différence et
sont les troupes ukrainiennes sont en
fait beaucoup plus mobiles et du coup
beaucoup plus efficace est-ce que l'aide
américaine est fondamentale à la hasard
bah c'est elle est importante bien
entendu mais c'est quand même les gens
qui combat bien sûr que sans arme c'est
très difficile d'avancer une de se
défendre ça c'est bien de soi mais c'est
aussi des canons au wither c'est ça
parce qu'en fait j'ai vu qu'il y avait
aussi une nouvelle il y a aussi
d'ailleurs les Césars français qui
marchent très bien il y a j'ai les très
bonnes échos des lignes de front des mes
amis qui combattent justement les cours
que vous avez de leur côté est-ce que
est-ce qu'ils ont effectivement encore
le moral est-ce que c'est
contre-offensif comme le disait
Gwendoline de Bono leur redonne font
qu'ils gardent le moral ils ont
l'impression qu'ils vont gagner bah
personne ne doute en fait je pense que
selon les sondages il y a 92% des
Ukrainiens sont persuadés que on va
gagner cette guerre on ne sait pas quand
on ne sait pas combien ça nous coûtera
en vieillement donc voilà mais sinon les
troupes ils sont très motivés il y a
beaucoup de gens autour de moi il y a
plein plein de gens qui sont partis qui
n'étaient jamais militaires dans le
passé qui était journaliste qui était
ingénieur ce que vous voulez et qui
sonne qui ne pouvaient pas faire
autrement donc il continue donc avoir
froid et une abonnée je sais que vous
avez des contacts sur le terrain ils ont
toujours fourni la victoire cette
contre-offensive leur rapporte un peu de
ukrainien c'est sûr moi je rentre du
crâne et c'est j'ai pas rencontré une
seule personne en Ukraine qui me dit
qu'il ne m'a pas dit mais c'est
complètement évident on va gagner la
guerre enfin pour eux c'est juste une
évidence c'est juste une question c'est
une finalement une modalité de gagner la
guerre ils s'en sont absolument
persuadés on vous a sorti non tout de
même parce que lorsqu'on regarde avec le
recul enfin la bataille c'est-à-dire que
de l'extérieur on a toujours eu
l'impression que c'est David contre
Goliath donc c'est ce qui est surprenant
c'est effectivement cette assurance des
Ukrainiens que que la victoire est à eux
que tout va bien se passer alors
évidemment avec des pertes terribles le
pays est en souffrance c'est une c'est
une tragédie pour l'Ukraine mais ils
sont ils disent qu'ils assument
pleinement ce sacrifice et ce sacrifice
ne vaut que la victoire il n'y a pas
d'autre issus possibles pour les
Ukrainiens par contre côté russe
effectivement la dynamique de la défaite
on en parlait à l'instant je pense
qu'elle se traduit pleinement par la
façon dont se déroule cette mobilisation
c'est-à-dire que on tente du point de
vue de la communication au Kremlin de
toujours cette structure cette assurance
que l'on maîtrise la situation etc par
exemple Vladimir Poutine annonçait la
mobilisation de 300 000 réservistes
expérimentés de gens qui sont entraînés
qui ont déjà combattu etc pour pour les
envoyer au front en tant que
professionnel ce que l'on voit dans les
faits et dans la réalité c'est qu'il y a
une réelle panique chaque région fait
d'usage pour envoyer le plus d'hommes
possible ils envoient des gens qui ne
passent pas les commissions médicales il
n'y a pas d'entraînement ils sont
envoyés directement au front il y a
toutes ces images qui circulent d'hommes
qui se font casser les jambes etc pour
pas y aller donc ça c'est vraiment c'est
clairement quelque chose qui montre le
désarroi la débâcle alors que eux
communiquent sur le fait justement que
ils ont ils ont déjà mobilisé 200 000
personnes c'est le communiqué du premier
aujourd'hui
comme on a réussi en deux semaines à
mobiliser 200 000 personnes en réalité
je pense que ces chiffres sont tout
aussi fictifs que l'objectif de des nazi
fier l'Ukraine c'est juste ce sont juste
des effets d'annonces quand on fait de
la mobilisation si on a 300 000 48
heures après on a 300000 et là le fait
que 15 jours après on annonce 200 000 ça
veut dire que la cette mobilisation n'a
pas été préparée et que il trouve des
palliatifs et comme vous le dites ils
annoncent 200000 on n'en sait rien mais
de toute façon c'est un échec c'est
clair la mobilisation le système russe a
changé en 2008 et il n'y a jamais eu de
répétition de la mobilisation depuis et
donc là on voit que c'est de
l'improvisation et donc avec ce que vous
dites c'est à dire qu'on est obligé
d'envoyer les gens au front directement
l'inverse c'est l'Ukraine qui a mobilisé
dès le début de la guerre et qui donc a
préparé entraîner ses troupes et qui
peut les envoyer en unité constituée
alors que là on envoie des soldats
rejoint des unités parce qu'il manque de
soldats tout bêtement en tout cas une
chose qui n'a pas été improvisée c'est
l'annonce et il se décrit signé
aujourd'hui par Vladimir Poutine qui a
finalisé l'annexion des quatre régions
ukrainiennes donc après ces fameux
référendum simulacre
ici les régions de Donetsk louansk
Carson et zapporja qui entrent donc
d'après ce avec ce décret de la guerre
Poutine dans la Fédération de Russie le
Kremlin aussi d'ailleurs promis de
récupérer les territoires perdus
récemment par Moscou à la je cite
Vladimir Poutine on va l'écouter
le ministère de la Défense
à signaler
qu'un certain nombre de catégories de
nos citoyens
non pas besoin d'être enregistré dans le
cadre de l'effort de mobilisation
et les a répertoriés
nous avons donc dû apporter des
ajustements à ce document en conséquence
j'ai déjà publié un décret aujourd'hui
il a déjà été signé qui fait ces mêmes
ajustements
c'est référendum derrière cette
addiction par justement Vladimir Poutine
de ces quatre provinces rien du tout
juridiquement ça vaut absolument rien
exactement comme l'annexion de la Crimée
et des facto aussi l'armée ukrainien
sans écouter Poutine y faire attention à
tout ce qu'il dit continuer d'avancer
sûrement donc l'humain était pris les
autres petits villages autour aussi la
contrainte au continue donc non pour
nous ça change absolument rien est-ce
qu'il y a justement une problématique de
frontière tout de même au lait
comme-csef en tout cas qui aimerait bien
faire jouer Vladimir Poutine alors il a
pas parlé de frontière très rigide
puisqu'on le sait donc il y a des
contre-offensives
ukrainiennes au sein de tous ces oblates
me semble-t-il il comprit à Donetsk
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce comment va-t-il
définir exactement donc ce qui devient
en fait russe à ses yeux en tout cas
est-ce qu'il le sait lui-même c'est là
comme vous dites c'est l'improvisation
c'est la et et non seulement c'est
l'improvisation mais c'est
l'improvisation dans une paille aille
noire mais là ça va également se
refléter diplomatiquement la place de la
frontière russe ou comprendre plus
compliqué justement aux Occidentaux
stalinien c'est comme ça qu'on a on a
dessiné d'une manière complètement
absurde les les frontières de l'Arménie
et de l'azerbaïdjano le résultat
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs justement c'est
dans en général dans une tactique
stratégie de diviser pour pour régner
créer des ambiguïtés des minorités ici
des minorités là rien d'homogène disons
et
mais en fait ça n'a jamais marché ça ça
a complètement fait exploser la
Yougoslavie puisque c'est la même pour
légitimer quoi parce que c'est comme ça
qu'on lui a pris de faire il faut il
faut arrêter de penser que c'est
quelqu'un de génial que c'est un grand
tacticien
je l'ai dit moi-même je le regrette
beaucoup parce qu'effectivement on voit
avec cette guerre les c'est un c'est un
stratège et un chef d'État extrêmement
médiocre en fait avec avec une
intelligence très limitée et on voit que
finalement il avance avec le nez dans le
des vieux manuels du KGB des années 70
c'est ça tout le problème je sais pas si
le général est d'accord avec moi mais
tout à fait sur les référendums
souvenons-nous que c'était vu début
septembre ça a été repoussé à début
novembre et puis d'un seul coup panique
c'est la semaine prochaine on a
l'impression qu'on a c'est vite faisons
cela avant que les territoires ne sera
repris puisque le français va avait déjà
commencé donc si vous voulez c'est
totalement de l'improvisation je crois
que la
qualité qu'on peut reconnaître à
Monsieur Poutine c'est d'être têtu c'est
c'est à dire qu'il a décidé quelque
chose tout se déroule suivant les plans
si on l'écoute et tout va aller comme ça
même si la réalité ne correspond pas à
ce qu'il dit
moi je pense que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est que ce projet
d'invasion de l'Ukraine c'est quelque
chose qui a été écrit de très longue
date que les technologies elle s'était
mise en place de très longue date la
création de ces républiques sépaid dites
séparatiste de Donia skadelouran c'est
quelque chose qui a été complètement
calqué sur les schémas de la
Transnistrie avec les mêmes services
secrets qui étaient venus qui avait mis
qui avait mis en place la République de
Transnistrie par exemple un Moldavie qui
sont allés ensuite implémenter ces
processus à deniers tout discours
propagandiste d'Occident qui a qui a
armé les nazis qui arrive au pouvoir en
Ukraine on l'avait entendu depuis la
Révolution orange en 2004 je veux dire
c'est vraiment pas nouveau ce discours
de la Grande Russie qui doit rejouer la
grande guerre patriotique etc donc en
fait quand on regarde entre ligne on
l'avait juste pas vu venir le discours
de Munich ce qu'il a répété au moment de
l'annexion mais en plus agressive
aujourd'hui le problème c'est que ce
plan qu'il a peut-être construit depuis
20 ans depuis que il est parti de dress
je n'en sais rien enfin en tout cas
depuis très longtemps Vladimir Poutine
depuis qu'il n'est plus à la tête du KGB
du FSB je pense qu'aujourd'hui
simplement ça ne marche pas d'où c'est
improvisation c'est la première fois en
fait peut-être que Vladimir Poutine est
forcée d'improviser dans un plan
impérialiste qu'il a de très longues
dates et c'est pour ça qu'on assiste en
fait à cette débâcle et à ce et et à cet
étonnement et assez défaite parce que
finalement ça ne marche pas du tout
comme prévu alors que même que c'était
un rêve de très très longue date et
prévu de très très longue date à
la première c'est que le plan initial
qui était que qui sera pris en trois
jours le rend verset du gouvernement
typique manoeuvre du FSB ça ça pouvait y
penser que ça marchait ça n'a pas marché
et il sait tout de suite heurté à la le
courage et à la lutte ukrainienne la
deuxième chose c'est que l'Ukraine est
totalement soutenu par l'Occident et là
d'un seul coup il a affaire un gros
morceau quand même et si on ajoute
l'incapacité de la Russie et de l'armée
russe a progressé et ben ça fait
complètement exploser tout ce à quoi il
pouvait prétendre cette incapacité de
l'armée russe ça vous avez même
vous-même surpris non parce qu'en fait
on parlait beaucoup de la puissance de
l'armée russe on joue toujours à se
faire peur je me souviens dans les
années 90 avant 1990 je faisais les
plans d'engagement du deuxième corps
d'armée on pensait que la trouée de
fulgar il percerait il y aurait pas de
problème et tout et quand on a découvert
les archives après
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'entre le discours Elena
c'est ce que dit général trinquant entre
le discours ton grand gars patriotique
et la réalité donc combien sont-ils
avoir fui grosso modo 200000 personnes
au début et peut-être encore 100000
aujourd'hui les chiffres sont très
difficiles à définir on peut juste
regarder les images et on pourrait
penser oui qui sont effectivement des
dizaines de milliers après parmi ces
dizaines de milliers il y en a sans
doute un très très grand nombre qui
disait effectivement qu'ils doivent
comme leur grand-parents combattre les
nazis etc c'est à dire que ce discours
là il marche mais comme c'est un une
construction encore une fois dogmatique
propagandiste qui joue sur des choses
très superficielles dans la conscience
collective russe ça ne marche pas à
partir du moment où la guerre s'invite
chez vous que vous êtes assis sur votre
divan à dire je soutiens l'opération
spéciale mais avant ça mais on vous dit
mais maintenant vous allez prendre une
arme et vous allez y aller
c'est facile de c'est facile de jouer
exactement d'ailleurs c'est facile de
rejouer la deuxième guerre mondiale
après avoir vu plein de films à la télé
parce qu'il y a une véritable religion
depuis quelques années en Russie c'est
très facile à jouer à ça et de se faire
des films dans la tête en regardant
ensuite des sauts opéra et en jouant un
Tik Tok une fois qu'on vient vous
mobilisez c'est autre chose c'est quand
même une autre génération là je suis
d'accord avec vous c'est une autre
génération il croyait peut-être que oui
moi je vais devenir un grand héros quand
on vient les chercher quand la réalité
arrive à la maison c'est autre chose et
on fuit vers la George
à
pour les Russes c'est possible mais ce
que je voulais dire que pour les
Ukrainiens la grande guerre pas critique
ça n'a pas du tout la même sens la
guerre patriotique pour nous c'est
maintenant parce que c'est là qu'on
défende notre pays c'est là que vraiment
tout le monde se lève pour aider l'armée
pour faire ce qu'on peut vraiment ce
qu'on peut pour essayer de mettre dehors
les adversaires et l'image de Grande
Guerre il est très controversé pour les
Ukrainiens parce que le crâne c'était
devenu le champ de bataille entre
d'autres territorismes rouge marron
on ne sait pas pour rien que
systématique Snyder appelez ça les
terres de sang mais pour nous on est
on se sentait juste au milieu de combat
des de gros monstres qui étaient les
deux colonisateurs pour nous donc la
guerre pathétique en Ukraine c'est
celle-ci c'est celle-ci aujourd'hui
vous êtes jeune moi je connais des gens
de l'autre génération qui ont connu qui
ont connu la guerre mais il y a une
chose je suis d'accord et pas d'accord
avec vous dans la mesure que la grande
guerre patriotique ça s'est déroulée en
partie en Russie mais c'est surtout en
Ukraine et en Biélorussie qui est que ça
s'est passé donc il n'ignore pas la il y
a toute une génération ceux qui ont même
disons qui ont mon âge qui sont nés 10
15 ans après la guerre ça leur est resté
quand même dans la tête et ils sont
justement absolument outragés de voir
finalement des gens
des gens de 30 ans qu'on en voit soit
disant pour des nazifié alors qu'ils ont
souffert sous le sous le nazisme
eux-mêmes il y a eu des nazis il faut
pas faut pas faut pas se leurrer il y a
des groupes extrémistes il y en a en
Russie aussi d'ailleurs et là on en
parle pas mais la guerre là il y a quand
même un patriotisme qui vient du
patriotisme soviétique mais en se disant
c'est nous surtout qui avons combattu
les nazis en Ukraine alors qu'on nous
accuse d'être né nazis donc ça ça motive
pour aller se battre et d'autre part
simplement là quand on est attaqué quand
on voit ses maisons sa propre maison
bombardée
là on a envie de défendre simplement
même sa famille c'est il y a un réflexe
complètement instinctif on est on a
envie de prendre les armes et d'agir
parce que voilà ils arrivent et ils
détruisent tout oui je voulais dire
qu'on a combattu contre le nazisme on a
combattu aussi contre contre les rouges
donc on a combatté contre les deux oui
pendant la guerre civile alors
effectivement c'est surtout l'Ukraine
qui a résisté à l'Armée rouge et on
parle de l'armée blanche comme si
c'était une bande d'aristocrates
attention c'était la grande résistance
contre l'Armée rouge c'était justement
des Ukrainiens pour revenir à la
contrefensive
on va parler du chantage nucléaire mais
juste avant est-ce qu'effectivement il y
a une échéance générale trinquant qui
est l'hiver prochain et que donc
aujourd'hui on est vraiment face à une
course contre la montre sur le terrain
ça va se passer dans les quelques
semaines qui viennent pas l'hiver les
petites raspoutidière c'est-à-dire les
pluies qui arrivent en novembre le
globalement
ça dépend de la météo je sais pas s'il y
aura beaucoup de pluie cette année c'est
comme la raspoutidja de printemps qui
empêche les mouvements l'hiver non quand
ça gèle au contraire les véhicules
blindés roulent très bien quand ça VL on
franchit les fleuves allègrement et ça
se passe beaucoup mieux en hiver que à
l'automne ou au printemps
en ce moment il y a une accélération en
ce moment parce que si Kerson tombe
avant la fin du mois et si le maximum
est pris avant la fin du mois ça sera ce
site gagné qui amènera une stagnation
pendant peut-être un mois un mois et
demi deux mois le temps que le gel voilà
quand le gel arrive ça permettra de
reprendre les mouvements donc en fait on
essaie de gagner du terrain maintenant
ensuite il y aura probablement un gel
des positions ce que vous dites et
ensuite une reprise du combat après donc
quand on dit gel des positions ça veut
dire stagnation c'est pas forcément
parce que il y a le gel à double sens
mais ceci étant on verra en suivant de
la météo ça c'est indépendant de la
volonté des Ukrainiens et des Russes
alors le chantage au nucléaires de
Vladimir Poutine est-il du bluff ou pas
parce que ça ça reste une question en
tout cas pour David Pétrus l'ancien chef
de la CIA l'Américain lui prend cette
menace très au sérieux on l'écoute
Justin give you
juste pour vous donner une hypothèse
nous répondrions en engageons un effort
collectif de l'OTAN qui éliminerait
toutes les forces conventionnelles
russes que nous pouvons voir et
identifier sur le champ de bataille en
Ukraine et en Crimée ainsi que tous les
navires en mer Noire
donc je rentre encore je recommence avec
vous parce que vous êtes le militaire de
splato donc là quand effectivement en
général Petrus dit ça ça veut dire que
si jamais effectivement il y avait une
attaque tactique avec une ogive
nucléaire de Poutine en Ukraine il y
aurait une riposte immédiate de l'OTAN
sur quoi des villes russes on note que
le général Pétrus se garde bien de dire
que le temps utiliserait le nucléaire
dit qu'on détruirait je pense que c'est
un message vis-à-vis des Russes en
disant on frappera pas la Russie on
détruira toute votre capacité donc c'est
un message d'une certaine façon qui est
pas à la hauteur de l'utilisation de
l'arme nucléaire voilà l'arme nucléaire
il faut toujours s'en méfier je dis pas
que
c'est impossible donc il faut s'y
préparer mais je n'y crois pas parce que
on rentre dans un champ tellement
différent tellement différent que
imaginez si Poutine utilisait l'harmonie
claire c'est un aveu d'échec majeur pour
lui et ça veut dire que les Russes les
Chinois les parents les Indiens les
Chinois qui sont censés soutenir parce
qu'il le soutiennent plus tellement mais
le soutiendrait plus du tout parce que
ça veut dire que leurs armes nucléaires
ne serviraient plus à l'addition puisque
l'arme nucléaire est une arme d'emploi
est-ce que justement les Ukrainiens se
disent pas qu'ils veulent l'utiliser
quand même cette arme créée nucléaire on
l'exclut pas on comprend qu'il est
capable de tout donc y compris de tous
les alarmes nucléaires mais on se fait
pas peur on essaie de faire exactement
comme dit le général trencant être prêt
parce que tout peut arriver on a vu que
Tchernobyl donc on a cette traumatisme
dans les jeunes mais en même temps on se
projette dans l'avenir
on garde notre sang-froid et on continue
de combattre en tout cas moi j'ai lu les
cops pour rebondir dans le Time en tout
cas donc le journaliste britannique le
journal britannique il y aurait des
possibles trains nucléaires qui
transporterait des équipements
militaires et qui viseraient justement
une préparation de l'utilisation de cet
arbre en Ukraine par Poutine
alors
que Poutine là nous parlons logique
il y a beaucoup de il y a beaucoup de
moyens qu'on peut être secrètement
exprimé les Américains directement au
Kremlin pour les menacer au cas où
Poutine utiliserait soit des armes
probablement pas des armes nucléaires
stratégiques mais des armes nucléaires
tactiques
il pourrait parier ils ont peut-être ils
ont peut-être déjà menacé alors c'était
il y avait peut-être une allusion la
Petrus il y a peut-être fait allusion
il se pourrait que si Poutine appuie sur
le bouton on coule toute la flotte de la
Baltique peut-être de la mer Noire et
pourquoi pas celle la flotte du
Pacifique déjà ils peuvent ils peuvent
ils pourraient faire cela au lieu de
même lancer des armes nucléaires mais
attention il y a le général le général
Clark qui a quelques heures où il
quelques jours a également déclaré on ne
peut pas non plus se baser sur ce qui
est logique et sur ce qu'on aurait envie
qu'il se passe il faut également se
préparer au pire
oui mais nous ne le souhaitons pas mais
ce serait illogique pour Poutine de le
faire mais malheureusement toute cette
guerre est illogique de toute manière il
aurait jamais dû commencer cette guerre
s'il avait un minimum de compréhension
de la société ukrainienne qui aurait
tant résisté il pensait qu'il allait
rentrer à Prague
parlons rentré à qui est-ce qu'on est
rentré à Prague en 68 c'est ça qui
s'imaginait ou alors un peu de combat
comment on gris en 1956 donc comme c'est
n'est pas quelqu'un qui résonne de
manière
intelligente et toujours c'est un
mauvais joueur d'échec finalement c'est
un joueur d'échec mais un mauvais joueur
d'échec et il peut être poussé au pire
alors surtout s'il y a des problèmes
psychologiques s'il est mourant ou quoi
il peut y avoir une dérive à la Jim
Jones d'autant plus qu'il y a des
idéologues et notamment parmi les
dirigeants religieux qui nous parlent en
fait de de locaux cette apocalyptique ou
finalement ce serait très bien parce que
ça sacrifiéait le surplus d'humanité
hier alors il y a un mélange de de
d'idéologie islamiste un mélange de
malthusianisme il y a trois quatre
idéologies extrémistes qui se mirant
mélange mais si ça parvient aux mauvais
moment à l'oreille de Poutine et bien il
faut être prêt à ceux qui fasse une
bêtise
d'où la riposte donc prévu a priori de
l'OTAN Elena vous me disiez vous que on
distribue quand même des pastides enfin
bon il y a on parle de catastrophe
nucléaire de la centrale nucléaire de
zapporisés voilà parce que ça c'est un
sujet aussi et en parlant il y a
effectivement l'utilisation donc des
ogives tactiques possibles et puis il y
a cette centrale nucléaire aujourd'hui
Vladimir Poutine a dit que c'était russe
puisqu'en fait il a annexé zapporijah
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire là aussi pour
y avoir d'abord un accident nucléaire on
peut pas l'exclure et en plus est-ce
qu'ils vont utiliser cette centrale
nucléaire maintenant pour peut-être
livrer de l'électricité déviée justement
l'électricité qui est livrée aux
Ukrainiens et aller la dévier vers la
Crimée par exemple qui est
occupé par les Russes moi sur ce sujet
là je rejoins l'argument de
l'irrationalité totale et il y a un
certain nombre de Léman très inquiétant
dans le discours russe d'abord le fait
que ils ont clairement annoncé le fait
que si l'Ukraine poursuit sa
contre-offensive sur ces territoires qui
sont désormais déclarés comme étant ceux
de la Fédération de Russie la Russie
percevrait cela comme une agression
envers son pays donc en fait c'est un
peu la prophétie auto réalisatrice qui
s'auto qui finit par s'auto justifier
c'est-à-dire qu'il l'avait déclaré dès
le départ que la Russie était agressée
etc et aujourd'hui en annexant ces
territoires il rentre cette situation
fictive réelle ensuite dans la doctrine
nucléaire russe ce qui justifierait
l'emploi de l'arme nucléaire par la
Russie serait que le territoire russe et
la Russie serait menacé dans son
existenceur dans son discours qui est de
plus en plus agressif de plus en plus
irrationnel justement Vladimir Poutine
parce que si vous avez écouté sa tirade
le jour où il annonçait l'annexion de
ces régions c'était extrêmement
c'était terrifiant en irrationalité en
fait enfin c'est à dire que c'est un
discours qui n'avait ni que ni tête du
début à la fin où il m'a mélangé
absolument tout il renversait l'histoire
où il disait que l'Occident avait drogué
des peuples entiers enfin voilà ça
c'était vraiment ça et on se dit
aujourd'hui il a le doigt sur le bouton
nucléaire et il n'arrête pas de dire en
fait que et la propagande russe n'arrête
pas de marteler qu'il n'y a pas de
retour en arrière possible que nous
devons gagner parce que sinon on
disparaîtrons et nous serons détruits or
Vladimir Poutine personnalise jusqu'à
l'extrême lui-même étant la Russie pour
lui la Russie n'existe pas sans l'une
n'existe pas sans son régime à partir du
moment où son régime est menacé pour lui
il peut même dire que l'existence même
de la Russie est menacée allant jusqu'à
peut-être donc vous l'exposé
plusieurs remarques la première remarque
c'est que les généraux américains qui
s'expriment ne sont plus en activité oui
donc c'est sûr mais c'est comme moi
on va faire ceci cela ça n'engage
absolument pas
renseigner mais bon
de très haut niveau donc ils sont bien
renseignés deuxième point le chef
d'état-major américain dit toujours qui
parle au chef d'état-major russe il se
parle et donc les avertissements dont
vous parlez il passe ses avertissements
en disant russe attention à ce que vous
alliez les faire etc de l'autre côté du
côté du côté russe
pardonnez-moi mais je trouve que l'image
du président Poutine le doit sur le
bouton et fausses l'armement nulle
claire ça veut dire que il prend une
décision pas seule et ensuite il faut le
mettre en oeuvre je rappelle juste un
petit incident pendant la crise de Cuba
l'ordre avait été donné d'envoyer un une
torpille nucléaire dans un sous-marin
russe et c'est le sous-marinier qui n'a
pas envoyé la torpille nucléaire
donc ça veut dire que il y a toute la
chaîne et donc si vous voulez le régime
serait plus raisonnable que le maître du
crèvement qu'on a avec le président
Poutine le problème c'est que le régime
tomberait mais il y a plein de gens
aujourd'hui autour de Poutine qui n'ont
pas envie que le régime tombe et donc
ils n'ont pas envie que Poutine aille
jusqu'à ce point-là parce que ça serait
la chute du régime c'est ça que vous
dites en fait si vous utilisez le
nucléaire ça serait la chute de Poutine
en fait
est-ce qu'ils s'en rend compte c'est ça
le problème et qui
mais qui est son entourage est-ce qu'ils
sont tellement plus intelligent que lui
ou pas
évidemment il ne vit que par le maître
et oui mais les armées par exemple on
parle d'armement tactique
l'armement tactique ce sont les armées
qui le mettent en œuvre donc il y a pas
seulement ces trois personnes ensuite
l'ordre doit être effectivement exécuté
alors on peut miser sur la mutinerie de
bas étage
en général je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous c'est probablement ce qui va
c'est probablement ce qui nous protégera
effectivement d'une guerre nucléaire
même même tactique mais il y a trop
d'éléments
instables et imprévus pour se rassurer
complètement mais il s'agit pas de il
s'agit pas de rassurer je reprendrai les
paroles du pape n'ayez pas peur il joue
avec nos nerfs c'est la guerre est un
affrontement de volonté oui donc il
pousse la volonté jusqu'au bout et si
vous écoutez bien en France vous avez un
certain nombre de gens qui disent
nucléaire attendez pourquoi on soutient
l'Ukraine on va quand même pas mourir à
cause de l'Ukraine mais oui mais il faut
pas se dégonfler
mais il faut oui mais il faut se
préparer il faut j'ai pas dit qu'il
fallait pas se préparer j'ai dit
simplement qu'il faut avoir la volonté à
hauteur du président Poutine pour dire
vous voulez l'utiliser nous on l'utilise
je vous rappelle
nucléaires les trois sont à la mer c'est
jamais arrivé avant donc
on se met au bon niveau le bout de la
fin peut-être une minute justement sur
cette menace nucléaire et là l'effet
qu'elle peut avoir sur les Ukrainiens je
viens de dire que les Ukrainiens ils
imaginent que ça peut arriver mais
encore une fois on se fait pas peur du
tout donc on garde notre sang-froid et
on se dit qu'il faut aussi ça arrive ça
arrive mais pour l'instant on continue
de combattre nous continuons à faire
tout ce qu'on a tout ce qu'on a à faire
maintenant avec l'espoir donc de gagner
avec les certitudes qu'on va gagner la
certitude merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous merci Elena et
nevolochine merci Dominique trinquant
général Dominique trinquant merci aux
lecope d'avoir été avec nous merci à
notre envoyé spécial Gwendoline de Bono
qui se trouve toujours donc dans le sud
de l'Ukraine à très bientôt Gwendoline
sur nos antennes et merci à vous tous de
nous avoir suivis vont rester avec nous
sur France 24